now we turn to congresswoman
ocasio-cortez who just proudly announced
that capitalism just is not a redeemable
system for us
really take a look
to me
capitalism at its core
what we're talking about when we talk
about that
is the absolute pursuit of profit at all
human environmental and social cost
that is what we're really discussing to
me that is not a redeemable system for
us to be able to participate in for the
prosperity and peace for the vast
majority of people
here with reaction senator marco rubio
who by the way just introduced
legislation that would ban the use of
arrest papers as identification for
illegal immigrants at airports uh the
fact that you have to bring that as
legislation is a little mind-numbing uh
you know there's a very large and
we were down in miami together we did
this town hall
there's a very large
cuban-american community vibrant
community in miami
and
i mean the people that suffered under
the castro regime i know have a very
very different opinion than aoc
on this issue of capitalism the greatest
wealth
producing system for anybody that wants
to work hard and drive themselves to
success
yeah i mean i'm not surprised by those
comments those comments are now the
mainstream of the democratic party and
either people believe that or they have
to pretend they believe in some of their
policies do um you know they woke up one
day and i guess decided that marxism was
right all along and that the cold war
should have never ended and i don't
understand how people that feel that way
don't just move to one of these other
countries there's so many other
countries out there that actually agree
with that sentiment about socialism
being better than than capitalism in the
real world the world i come from the
neighborhood that i grew up in the
people i've grown up around my family
capitalism is not these big corporations
capitalism is the small business owner
it's the person that started it out of
the you know basement of their or their
home or their garage and now owns a
small business and employs four people
that's not possible in any other system
but the capitalist free enterprise
system that's the only system in the
world that's ever been possible where
someone can come here legally from
another country and in a short period of
time be the owner of a business and
control their own economic destiny
provide for their families and jobs for
others like them so look i think it's a
great debate to have we should have it
it's important to reinvigorate in every
generation the belief in capitalism but
this this sort of rejection of it and
this embraces socialism uh by the
congresswoman you just said i mean that
that's now the mainstream of the
democratic party the so she wants this
green new deal which would basically be
you know cradle to grave wound to the
tomb redistribution of wealth my
question is i have a hard time
understanding
where
this belief that government can be
successful now the same government that
bankrupted social security and and
medicare they're both headed for
insolvency they there was no lock box
they they raided the lock box and
squatted the money the same people that
destroyed our school system in many
towns and cities across the country the
same people that promised keep your
doctor keep your care and save money
well millions lost their doctors
millions lost their care and we're all
paying about 200 plus percent more um
the same people that can't keep law and
order why would we trust them with any
other aspect of our daily lives
because socialism is not about economics
it's a big mistake that we make it
social there's nothing to it's about
power it's about the ability to control
people if you control where people work
if you control how much they make if you
control who owns what then you can
control what they say you can control
who they hire you can control what they
can sell what they can do what hours
they can open it's about power it's
about control that's what socialism has
always been about socialism ultimately
is not possible the socialism she's
talking about and they talk about it's
really not possible without a government
that actually controls every aspect of
your life because and that's why i think
i don't think they're that troubled by
inflation i think they like the fact
that inflation's run amok and that
prices are high because that just means
that they can come in with the argument
that you see the market can't provide
for your needs only a government check
can only government guarantee can it
plays right into their hands but again
socialism is not about economics it's
about power it's about control that's
why people flee that's why miami you
know has inherited eight hundred
thousand to a million people from latin
america who flee socialism because it
fails and it destroys lives
i'll quote ronald reagan and end the
segment with government is the problem
senator always great to have you thank
you for being with us hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else